[Musique]
tu penses que tu peux me réparer gène tu n'es
pas cassé
[Musique]
belle amie
l'esprit est une chose fragile il suffit d'
un petit coup pour le faire basculer dans la mauvaise
direction
Charles qu'as-tu fait je devais garder une
écurie je l'ai protégé  elle de la vérité
il y a un autre mot pour eux je suis venu
chercher des réponses tu as l'impression que tu
n'appartiens pas ici tu n'es pas ils ne peuvent pas
commencer à comprendre ce que tu es
elle change c'est ce que tu n'es pas venu
ici chercher des réponses  tu es venu
ici pour demander la permission
elle a arrangé la douleur qui
sort de nous Jean a perdu le contrôle était-elle
encore Fed c'est de ta faute Charles
le monde est au bord du gouffre Je suis désolé de
ne pas l'avoir arrêté plus tôt tu es toujours
désolé  Charles
et il y a toujours un discours et personne ne
s'en
soucie encore ne fais pas ça
[Musique]
ils ont raison de me voir j'ai vu le nombril
je le regarde maintenant
[Applaudissements]
toi